so your first acting credit on your IMDB
page I believe was for flash fire yeah
it's with Billy Zane Lou Gossett jr. and
kristin minter what was that like that
first day on set can you take us to that
that time was that your first real huge
set that you'd ever been no because I
had already done commercials by that
time it was my first actual acting gig
I'm commercials are still you're still
acting but it wasn't like a narrative
you know where you had to just sit a
smile look pretty and and you know
pitched the product this was a natural
seeing that i had and i was being
directed and so it was it was fun i
remember going into the audition and
really committing to the role and I mean
it was like one line but it was like
committed dress like it and the director
said well you're really committed and so
that got me the part but I think we all
do that who you know really wanna a
career in this business so it was
exciting it was it was exciting but I
had already been on set so it wasn't
like oh this is new except the PSA when
we all got there because most of the
actors who were in this PSA were very
new I think it was like all of our first
gig and we were all sort of standing
around the craft service table where all
the food is just standing there we were
so hungry but no one would touch it
because we didn't know what the protocol
was we didn't know that that food was
there for us so we all just stood we're
like my life it looks really good but
none none of us would touch it until the
PA walked by and they're like you guys
are hungry we dome into that table so
that that experience was much more
memorable because it was my first
but by the time i did a flash fire i had
been on sets a couple times but working
with a director in a narrative form was
different because he was sort of you
know actor and a commercial is different
than the director on television and film
that experience was different in fun how
was it in the beginning working with
big-name talent I was just listening to
a radio program with um Danny McBride
the other day he was just talking about
you know coming to this town from
Virginia and being this young kid and
like oh my gosh does George Clooney and
I've got to remember my lines and I've
got to stay composed so do you remember
you know going to those first initial
jobs where you were you know there's a
Lou Gossett jr. on the set and you're
keeping your composure trying to
remember that one line or whatever it
was I think but before I started acting
in bigger projects with name actors I
had a friend who would crash Hollywood
parties and he would take me along I
mean I don't know how he did it he would
just get into any party anytime so
during that experience I met so many
celebrities like and I so I think I got
the whole wow there's Bruce Willis I
think we crashed the last boyscout
premiere party you know you know
the american music awards i member i
carry and you know all these marky mark
at the time and so i had gotten it out
of my system by the time i was working
as an actor I was more focused on the
professional aspect of it and I just
wanted to do what was right for the
character but there have been moments
where you are on set you sit back and
you're like oh my god these are all like
really famous people 12 Angry Men was
that wow moment because I was in the
presence of William Friedkin who I had
been huge fan of still AM and but you're
so nervous and focused on like just
doing the work that you don't think
about anything else but there was a
moment where I was on set and he came up
to me and he gave me some notes some
direction and then he walked away and I
was like wait a minute I just I just was
directed by I'm afraid kid oh my god get
into character so there was a those
moments you know there was edward james
olmos who I known growing up and you
know Jack lemon and George see Scott so
all these actors who was just sitting
across from me 12 of them really
well-known actors and there was that
well moment like
this is cool what would you advise to
other actors starting out who are maybe
not from LA because you sounds like you
were exposed to all of that earlier on
maybe they're from some smaller town
where you don't see these people at the
grocery store yeah how do they get over
that initial starstruck because I think
there's a there's an initial period for
people that come here there were you
just your jaw drops and you can't
believe you just saw you know yeah
everyone you know it's different because
I grew up here this is my hometown Los
Angeles so they were always filming
outside my house I think it was what's
his name from Jaws Roy boyfriend Josh
yes right he was outside my house cuz
they were filming in front of my house I
got to meet him and one of princes girls
at the time I was her apollonia
Apollonia yes she was outside so being a
you know Angelina I was exposed to a lot
of that as a kid and my good friend
Sandra worked at a video store and she
had called my brother and said it Arnold
Schwarzenegger is at the video store so
my brothers like let's go and he got a
goddess in the car and drove to the
video store and we got there and Arnold
was there but it wasn't really funneled
she had just because she works at a
video store she had the promotional big
life-sized Arnold Schwarzenegger so as a
kid we were always in like Damon Wayans
would come regularly to that video store
and that was during in living color so I
was a kid I was very much exposed to
that anyone outside of that and I
many friends who do I have a lot of
people who come and visit me from all
over the world and they do get
starstruck I think it's wonderful I
think it's you know because i think when
we go outside of our home base we
probably look starstruck when where you
see like the Eiffel Tower and the French
are probably like whatever you know
we're like look at it so beautiful Paris
is beautiful so I think they're there is
that moment that's how I can relate to
their experiences when I'm somewhere
else and I see someone but yes there are
a lot of actors who I respect and admire
and hope to achieve some of the success
that they've had or or at least the
respectability that they've achieved you
know Gary Oldman's an actor I admire and
so seeing an actor like that would
probably give me that all that kind of
like wow my job just dropped
you